wir sind jetzt verbunden mit ralf
stegner dem spd-abgeordneten im
auswärtigen ausschuss des bundestags
guten morgen herr stegner
was wissen sie darüber wie viele waffen
und panzer die bundesregierung bereits
in die ukraine geliefert hat
sie wissen ja dass die vereinbarung ist
dass dir der inhalt von hoffen die
frauen nicht öffentlich gemacht wird das
halten was nicht nur die deutschen
sondern die franzosen zum beispiel sagen
gar nichts was sie liefern uns
zum zweiten gibt es eine vereinbarung
innerhalb der nato des bündnisses dass
keine kampfpanzer geliefert werden ich
hatte ja schon auch sagen ich weiß nicht
ob wir unseren kanzler wünschen sollten
der das macht was wir gar nicht
meinungsumfragen sagen was irgendwelche
rüstungskonzernen sich wünschen oder was
die opposition fordert der kanzler muss
auf der basis seiner abstimmung mit den
verbündeten das tun was die
bundesregierung gemeinsam entschieden
hat das ist jedenfalls wenn man im
kanzleramt sitzt hierzu entscheidende
kriterium und nicht ströme interviews
meinungsumfragen spiegel natürlich aber
auch die meinung des volkes wider die
den kanzler dann indirekt auch gewählt
haben bloß natürlich hat man auch sehr
klare signale aus der ukraine welche
waffen dringend benötigt werden und dort
auch immer wieder deutschland in der
kritik das muss sich der kanzler aber
dann doch anhören oder und da wird die
meinungsumfragen angeht sind ja sehr
schwankend wir erleben sehr klar das ist
eine unterstützung dafür gibt das thema
im kanzleramt sitzt er in fragen von
krieg und frieden besonders und die
frage einerseits prüft wieder werde
ukraine am besten helfen können immer
gemeinsam mit den verbündeten allein und
zum zweiten auch dafür sorgt dass ihr
selbst ist im krieg herausgehalten
werden wenn er nicht ausgereift und was
die wünsche der ukraine an geht es eben
in der tat so dass es teilweise auch
dinge gibt wo die nato gemeinsam
entschieden hat ihn nicht zu folgen weil
man eben nicht im hineinschnuppern
möchte und auch nicht alles was einfach
nicht behauptet wird es war also zum
beispiel wird unter dem begriff schwere
waffen unterschiedlich ist verstanden
schwerer waffen umfassen auch gepanzerte
fahrzeuge die sie herum geliefert werden
aber sie umfassend halt auch kampfpanzer
oder kampfflugzeuge die nicht geliefert
werden und dass man immer differenziert
betrachten ich glaube auch nicht dass
man das alles verhängen darf immer nur
auf die frage von waffenlieferungen sind
wir reden über sanktionen wir gegenüber
humanitäre politische ökonomische etwa
das spielt alles auch eine rolle und
ihre militärische fragen finde ich nicht
angemacht naja aber viele bürgerinnen
und bürger hier in deutschland sind ja
auch eben unzufrieden damit wie sich der
bundeskanzler jetzt gerade präsentiert
dass er eben kaum ansprachen hält und
dass er irgendwie nicht wirklich neu
aber ist und sie haben es gerade gesagt
viele bürger seien aber vielleicht auf
der anderen seite auch froh dass olaf
scholz so besonnen handelt müsste er
seine besonnenheit aber vielleicht
einfach deutlicher erklären
und ich kann dass der bundeskanzler hat
schon mehr öffentliche ansprachen
gehalten und sich häufig an die medien
gestellt dass seine vorgängerin die
viele viele jahre im amt gewesen das
sind auch stolz ist das gerade mal 140
tage oder wie viel das sind man kann
kommunikation immer verbessern gar keine
frage es gibt ja debatten auf dem
deutschen bundestag darüber aber ich
finde die kritik teilweise vordergrund
nicht und ganz ehrlich am ende kommt es
nicht darauf an ob man in kiew gewesen
ist oder nicht sondern ob man alles
mögliche tun was vertretbar ist und was
nützlich ist um die ukraine zu
unterstützen das ist der entscheidende
punkt war nicht das was
oppositionspolitiker dazu sagen ein
bisschen wie soll ich sagen posieren ist
er ja auch dabei wenn ich höre aus der
märz alles bewirkt haben wird mit seinen
besuchen dann ist das ja auch ein
bisschen übertrieben
selbst vom himmel aber doch erfährt man
doch bei solchen besuchen auch was die
ukraine braucht und was sie will dafür
sind diese besucher da und man setzt ein
ganz deutliches signal der solidarität
finden sie das in ordnung dass es bisher
vom kanzler in dieser form nämlich durch
eine reise nach kiew noch nicht gab ich
kann das sagen signal der solidarität
setzt man vor allen dingen dadurch dass
man entschieden unterstützt kein land
hat es in europa die ukraine ökonomisch
stärker unterstützt kein land
unterstützt die politisch stärker wir
müssen wir machen das gemeinsam der
französische präsident war jetzt auch
noch nicht in kiew und wir haben
gemeinsam mit unserem französischen
monaten also kann man unterschiedlicher
meinung sein am ende kommt es auf die
substanz des handelns an und nicht auf
den äußeren eindruck und da gibt es eben
auch unterschiedliche meinungen zu der
frage viele realisieren dass der kanzler
ist nach afrika fährt dabei ist es
extrem wichtig weil wir die
energieversorgung sichern wollen die
jetzt gerade nötig ist weil wir
bestimmte dinge nicht aus gosheim
beziehen werden können oder auch mit den
staaten sprechen diese aktion nicht
angeschlossen haben es ist wichtig das
zu tun und deswegen finde ich jedenfalls
ein kanzler der in der substanz stark
ist es mir deutlich lieber als eine
flotte öffentlichkeitsarbeit hat das
festhalten hier sehen wir sie gerade an
der verteidigungsminister in empfinden
sie das auch als stark da schauen sie
die verteidigungsminister ist auch 140
tage im amt als zu beginn dieser neuen
regierung und ich finde die kritik
teilweise sehr sehr oberflächlich wenn
ich das mal vergleiche mit 16 jahren cdu
verteidigungsminister die lange jahre im
amt sein was sie hinterlassen haben was
jetzt noch aufgeräumt werden muss dann
finde ich das teilweise selber mal
wirklich nicht am ende wird foul an dem
gemessen was sie zugunsten der
bundeswehr gewirkt haben wird und das
wird am ende die längste periode sein
aber nicht nur 140 tagen und nicht
bezogener stücke schuhe oder wasser oder
inhalt der kritik sein mag würden sie
denn sagen dass gerade einen guten job
also ich kann nur sagen die
verteidigungsminister kümmert sich darum
die bundeswehr in ordnung zu bringen die
ziemlich herunter gewirtschaftet worden
es von 16 jahren cdu
verteidigungsminister und das ist
wichtiger dass das am ende rauskommt
dass wir in der landesverteidigung
stärker sind dass das sondervermögen
kommt da taktiert die union über uns
auch
der oppositionsführer und alles andere
wird dann bewertet und nicht nur 140
tagen hersteller jetzt zum abschluss
noch eine frage den mit sicherheit nach
jetzt nämlich heiß hergeht singen heute
nicht besonders gut das muss ich zugeben
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass es anders
ausgegangen wäre aber so ist das leben
und so ist der sport gelegentlich hat
man eben nicht das nötige glück uns da
muss wieder neue hände kommen und ich
hoffe es klappt beim nächsten mal
stecken dafür herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch sehr gerne